Janvier 2013, à l'autre bout du monde, un film se prépare.
Avant le tournage, le réalisateur a confié le repérage à un duo de professionnels:
Jane Ravenwood, cadreuse colonel au département vidéo de l'U.S Navy,
et Bob Drinking, triple champion du monde de repérage en 2009 et 2010.
*En anglais*
Si Bob Drinking est devenu une légende dans le monde du repérage,
c'est parce qu'il n'hésite pas à jouer lui-même les scènes du scénario.
Et ce afin de donner au réalisateur les prises de vues les plus saisissantes possible
Mise en scène par l'équipe, l'attaque du Dinoshark promet d'être spectaculaire.
*En anglais avec accent français*
La mise en scène de Bob est impressionnante.
L'équipe est maintenant prête à s'attaquer au premier problème d'ordre logistique :
Comment nourrir une équipe de 300 personnes.
La noix de coco : sorte de pomme de terre locale et présente en grande quantité.
Malheureusement,
A raison de 35 minutes d'ouverture par noix de coco,
multipliés par 300 noix de coco par repas,
il faudrait à l'équipe environ 7 jours de travail par repas.
La piste est abandonnée.
Après l'échec de la chasse au crabe,
l’équipe décide de se tourner vers la jungle.
Utilisant ses connaissances militaires acquises dans la NAVY,
Jane aide Bob à identifier les nombreux végétaux comestibles qui foisonnent dans ses régions luxuriantes.
*bruit de vomi*
La piste est également abandonnée.
L’équipe se tourne alors vers la pêche.
Les eaux chaude et extrêmement poissonneuses de la régions constituant un garde-manger inépuisable.
Après des débuts difficiles,
Jane finit de par faire de belles prises.
L’équipe décide de rester quelques jours sur place.
*anglais*
Sur les conseils d'un collègue,
Bob entame des négations avec un petit producteur local.
L'idée de rajouter des singes radioactifs bodybuildés demande a l'équipe d'organiser rapidement un casting.
Pour des questions budgétaires,
la production ne peut pas rajouter les dinosaures en post-production.
Une seul solution:
filmer directement de vrais dinosaures.
Mais malgré la bonne volonté des habitants,
c'est cette fois le réalisateur qui met un frein au projet.
Alors que la situation s’enlise en production à cause de l'ego du réalisateur,
sur place l'ambiance reste bonne.
Bob et Jane loin du narcissisme despotique d'un artiste immature...
Celui le disant étant celui qui y est, la narration continue.
Ainsi Jane expérimente des techniques de cadre nocturne sous l’œil amusé de Bob
L'équipe profite même de ses instants de répis pour régler quelques derniers détails
Les chorégraphies des combats sont mis au point selon les directives de Mat'.
Les "concepts arts" de l'affiche du film, sont réalisés par des artistes locaux.
Des groupes de musiques sont auditionnés pour composer la bande originale.
Le choix de l'équipe se porte sur un groupe de troubadours alternatifs: les "ON-OFF".
Enfin, acteurs et réalisateurs trouvent un compromis scénaristique.
Sur les conseils de Ty , un informateur local qui prétend pouvoir les mener jusqu'à la grotte des derniers vampires nazis encore en activité, l'équipe monte une expédition.
Par mesure de précaution, Bob décide d'emmener avec eux 5 vierges dont le sang fera diversion
en cas d'attaque vampire. Durant des jours, l'équipe s'enfonce dans l'épaisse forêt,
elle aussi inviolée.
Enfin, Ty souffle dans la plante à bubulles, signe qu'ils viennent de pénétrer sur le territoire des vampires nazis.
A partir, de ce point un camouflage de touriste allemand est obligatoire.
Ce n'est que plusieurs kilomètres plus loin que l'entrée de la grotte se dresse enfin devant eux.
Equipés de torches de fortunes, Bob et Jane pénètrent dans l’obscurité avec appréhension.
Malgré son palmarès impressionnant, Bob n'a jamais négocié avec des vampires.
Tous espèrent que les vierges suffiront à s'assurer leur collaboration.
C'est une cruelle déception pour l'équipe. Trompés par le guide qui s'enfuit déjà en hélicoptère,
Bob et Jane réalisent que les vampires sont en fait de simples chauves souris,
dont l'obédience nazie semble plus que douteuse.
Pour Bob, cette supercherie n'a vraiment rien de super.
Abattus et au bord de la rupture, c'est pourtant une découverte incroyable qui attend l'équipe.
Sans le savoir, en allant uriner, Bob vient de mettre à jour un temple perdu depuis des millions d'années.
Enfouie au cœur de la jungle, la cité légendaire de Ping-Pong représente un décor à l'authenticité parfaitement préservée.
Après les tests d'explosion, le feu vert des effets spéciaux est donné.
Pour Bob et Jane le repérage est terminé.
Si "Matthieu Poggi and the lost island" s'annonce effectivement comme le film d'aventure le plus ambitieux de tout les temps,
il ne fait aucun doute que sa suite, repoussera encore les limites du genre.
Les toutes dernières images envoyées par Bob et Jane sont encourageantes